freshness has never been my concern
every now and again i'll post some
things and we'll go that's old and I'm
like I don't care if it's old it's part
of the story it's part of the peas it's
a piece of the puzzle
what is the message of your newest novel
and how does it fit in with the previous
work that you know I don't know that it
has just one message but the thing that
I hope that that young people take away
from the work that I do is that
technology makes it cheaper to organize
and what that does is it levels the
playing field between the powerful and
the powerless and today there's three
very few people who are more powerless
alone people i mean we chase them out of
every public place and then as soon as
they find a place online to hang out we
chase them out of there too because
they're an attractive nuisance for
pedophile and it just I think it must
suck to be a kid today but at the same
time do you think it's like never been
better to be a good well so i think that
the axis of the tools gives you the
opportunity to do things that are pretty
awesome but you know we are attitude
towards kids today would not be
countenance for any other group i mean
in london they've developed this thing
called via the mosquito generates a
high-pitched tone that only kids can
hear in adults can it's really annoying
and they play it to keep kids moving
along stop them from hanging up imagine
if you made a tone that only Jews could
hear only you know black people can hear
only why people get here and you played
it outside of your store all day to stop
there i'ma congregating and you'd be
lynched what what explains the you know
the overriding prejudice against kids or
the fear of kids I mean especially there
seems to be less reason than ever to be
worried about kids today I mean they
they do less drugs they have less sex
they volunteer more so why are we here
at all through at least you know you
ever you go you know on the one hand I
guess it's just fear itself we've got a
wii we fear lots of things i feel like
we fear more things today that we've
fears when i was growing up and what
the things that that we've got is the
strange thing where we not only fear
kids we fear for them so when we're not
punishing and locking down kids because
we're afraid of them we're punishing and
locking them down because we're afraid
of all the bad things that might happen
to them seems like a a winning
combination 44 total dysfunction how old
is your daughter she's doing Hannah do
you let her wander around London by
yourself at two and a half no not yet
but you know we've got a little we live
in a little tear suspending our house is
one of six little cottages on the roof
of another building it's a long story
they big hill pulled them down after the
war and they rebuilt them at the top of
this office building so you know there's
guardrails she's not going to fall off
and there's nowhere else you can go and
we know all our neighbors so she runs up
and down the terrace all day you know
with that US team with us being in our
flat or maybe being outside we don't
watch her very closely are you
optimistic that she'll grow up in a
better world than you did and do you
feel that you grew up in a better world
than your parents in some really
empirical ways I did I mean my dad was
born in a refugee camp in Azerbaijan to
red army deserters right i mean there's
lots about at least my first six years
but are better than his first six years
is refugee moving across europe to
germany right the thing that i hope my
kid gets is that she gets to get back on
that swing of technology when it goes
from disrupting the status quo by making
things less free to disrupting the
status quo by making things more free
because i think technology swings back
and forth his boing boing still fresh
I feel I'm why so Boing Boing is now
I've never worried about being fresh
I've always bozizé bundling is the place
where I keep track of all the fragments
that seem like they're on piece of
something bigger and and by writing them
up for public consumption it helps me
understand them better remember them and
every now and again they coherent like a
novel or a short story or speech or an
article or a nonfiction book and so
fresh this has never been my concern
every now and again I'll put some things
and we'll go that's old I'm like I don't
care if it's old it's part of the story
it's part of the piece it's a piece of
the puzzle you know and I need to put it
on the table because I'm going to find
another piece that it matches but has
been the effect of offering you your
books for free online and then selling
them conventionally through tor well I
think it's increase my sales I don't
know how you would determine that
empirically you have to release the same
books without abreu to promise license
comparable sales you know little brother
was a bestseller on the New York Times
list for you know over a month that it
sold 90,000 hardcovers who sold the
language rights something like 20
countries now the film rates went to the
guy who made transformers you know it's
doing pretty well maybe it would have
done better with other CC licenses maybe
it would have done worse but you know
that the plus side for me has been in
addition to I feel like I've got more
sales I've also had the I've been able
to look myself in the mirror in the
morning because i haven't had to be a
hypocrite who pretends he doesn't copy
all day long and run wag my finger at
other people and I feel like I've been
able to make 20th century our 21st
century art art that's intended to be
copied you know I think if you're making
contemporary art and you don't think
that it's going to be copied it's not
really contemporary it's more like being
you know the blacksmith at Pioneer
Village that's cool but I'm a science
fiction writer I want to make
contemporary what is what's your next
project I'm working on a novel right now
called pirate cinema it's it's another
young adult novel to have kids in
Britain whose families have lost their
internet access because they download
too many movies to make their own
mashups and to spare their families the
shame of living with a downloader they
move to London for a street gang called
the jammie Dodgers and declare war on
the entertainment industry when is
unlikely to be out well let's do for
Christmas and
it'll lead to be out may or the
following on